[Music]
hello everyone this is chess for Knights
today we're going to talk about a wild
wild variation but first can anyone tell
me what was Fisher's favorite opening
against the Sicilian yes in the Sicilian
yes with black deny Dorf
and even there he had a specific line
that he loved can anybody tell me what
was his biggest favorite yes the
poisoned pawn variation and that's what
we're going to talk about today Bishop
g5 e 6f 4 can it can someone help me how
to reach the poisoned pawn position yes
Queen b6 the classical move is Queen d2
Queen takes B to rugby 193 was featured
in his match against Spassky and it was
many many years ago but it's still
thrilling would be one Queen a three and
now originally f5 was the main variation
in the 70s 80s but the main inventor of
the poisoned pawn with white was Paul
Karras and he found a move here which
suddenly became popular again in 2014-15
what does the move that Karis found in
this position and became topical
obviously white is upon down so he needs
to get active quickly otherwise he'll
just be suffering
how can my try to open
the position in here yes Bishop c4 is
away but Karis wanted to open up the
position immediately yes II five if I've
shockingly a very old move and this was
invented by Karis who was one of the
best players of his time a big rival of
a lien and Botvinnik and even thoug he
found this idea against tallish in 1957
d takes f e5 f takes e5 97 now why does
a pawn down but what does white have in
exchange for the pawn yes the center he
owns the center and also something else
which is very important in chess anyone
back there can you help me what kind of
advantage does white have in this
position yes yeah time the developmental
advantage is on white side so white
needs to keep up and keep that time
advantage and for that reason a lot of
moves were playing in this position
Tawes famous game against Ola Sherman
with will be three trying to win some
champion gaining more lead in
development and there's two other moves
that can be played here any ideas what
would you play in this position yes
that's you mean night b5 night b5 well
that's a typical idea in this position
but at the moment it would just lose a
piece because of a takes b5 so how can
why try to develop the attack and
continue having a lead in development
yes this should be three years away how
else can we try to develop the
initiative
which in which on which square do we
have the typical sacrifice in deny Dorf
the e6 square the typical sacrifices
happen on e6 so the next move is fairly
logical for white and actually was
played by Billick which one was that
yeah oh it's white to move yes
Knight takes c6 would be too early
because the pawn would capture they're
still in deep opening phase so we can't
really sacrifice already we need to
bring more pieces into the game to
actually have some chances to sacrifice
yes yes Bishop c4 and actually what is
shocking
Fisher refuted this very simple looking
and very natural looking move Bishop c4
and I'll show two of his games how he
deals with it now if we're playing on
black side
what's our biggest problem yes you know
no peace development at all exactly so
if we know the problem we're almost at
the solution so what should we do them
if we're behind development yes develop
yes now the question is how yes Bishop
c5 yeah I'm a bit I find that move a
little bit suspicious because the Queen
likes to drop to see if at at times but
you're very close yes
night see 696 feels a little bit slow
because our King is in danger to be
stuck in the center yeah Knight takes e5
would grab a pollen but wouldn't help
our development so Bishop c5 was very
close it was a bishop move what Fisher
played
yes he should before he didn't play
Bishop before but it's a legit move he
actually played yes Bishop e7
why has this leader of development but
if black manages to castle in time he
might have enough chances to hope Bishop
takes six and now Fischer plays a very
nice prophylactic move which would be
very easy to find in today's age but
it's a quite tough move in the 70s and
60s he still wants to develop yes
castles now if he would take on e6 black
would be a piece of but he wouldn't have
the time to castle at all
for example if Bishop takes g5 check
let's say King f8 checks again Knight
takes d5 Knight takes e5 and white
castles then might has huge attacks for
plenty of reasons can we list some
reasons why White's attack is so strong
here yes yes
yes yeah the white rook controls the F
file that's one good reason what other
good reasons you have that might has
this huge attack yes black can't castle
because it moved once yes and there
could be a third reason why black is
actually in big trouble yes yes and yeah
the king is totally unsafe and also
there are not enough pieces that could
cover up the king it will take like two
three moves to bring pieces near the
black King so white has a huge attack
here so Bishop takes six castles castles
and when you have advantages in the
position what what you should be aiming
for yes I mean we doubled our pieces but
when we are getting advantages if we
have an extra pawn or piece for example
what are we aiming to do in that case
yes exchanges yes and that's what
Fischer does exactly how did he do that
in this position yes Bishop takes g5
contains g5 and now he plays another
brilliant prophylactic move which is
easily overlooked yes
knight c6 no not knight c6
there would be some problems with Knight
f5 because even though we're confident
in this position is great for black
because Fischer is playing black it is
quite dangerous so black needs to be
extra precise to stay afloat yes
you can't really take the knight on c3
because of 9f5 ideas king gage one and
you're in big attack so there's a one
fine little move that Fischer plays and
it's gonna be a big deal later on yes
exactly
h6 now this little move might seem like
an average move to us but it's actually
a big deal
because the Queen was superbly placed on
g5 as our Jim mentioned Queen takes c3
then we run into Knight f5 with big
threats around the black King and that
happens because the Queen and Knight
works together so well but if we play h6
the Queen will have to move and Knight
f5 ideas won't work anymore Queen h4
Queen takes c3 and now he takes because
there's no more Knight f5 ideas rook
takes f7 rook takes f7 it was kind of a
must because otherwise we'll have very
little control over the pieces let's say
King h8 rook takes a fade Knight takes
Queen d8 and we have troubles here so
rook takes f7 Queen d8 night f8
Bishop takes f7 what should we do here
yes
yeah it takes because the white pieces
are getting really close and if we don't
compensate it with some piece advantages
you'll get into beat big big deep
trouble King takes f7 rook f1 and now
comes a brave move from Fischer yes yes
King g6 not fearing anything the King
moves out in the open
rook takes F and plays this little cute
move Bishop d7 now this looks very
awkward right it's pretty awkward this
bishop feels uncertain on d7 but it has
a point
what for one it defends the piece for
two it has a threat what does Bishop d7
threaten yes
the knight on d4 exactly so Knight f3 we
need three check King h1 and black has
like two concerns in this position are
those two concerns yes mm-hmm
okay that the queen is important yes the
King is unsafe it's not very safe
especially not on g6 so the biggest
threat would be what what White's
biggest threat in this position what
move is it yes
well yeah but how can how can we capture
the white the black King on g6 yes not
h4 check so if we see the threat we can
play against it and that's just fish
blood Fisher does how can we stop white
from playing Knight h4 yes
Queeny for doesn't really stop it
because if I play Knight H for you can't
take it because I defended the Queen yes
Queen c1 checked so sometimes Fischer
plays active moves so he can avert this
Knight threat of not h4 so he plays an
IG one here Queen takes c2 now he grabs
a different pump and actually Queen
takes c2 is not just grabbing a pawn it
actually sets up a very nice threat what
is blacks potential plan in this
position yes yes and actually we didn't
really talk about blacks other concern
the rook on a eight which is kind of
boxed in by its own pieces but at the
moment like is a piece of and Fischer
did a very good job averting danger the
knight is passive there and also he's a
piece of rook g8 Queen f2 why does he
play Queen f2 here what's the idea yes
no he played Queen f2 why did he play
clean f2 yes
and actually you suggest this bishop c6
but it runs to Queen f6 check that's the
problem with that
so in fact Fischer is defending of
peanut six ideas that's why he plays
screen after rook a fait and now takes
on a to Fischer obviously doesn't want
to draw rook f3 King h7 and we can see
that White's attack attack went into
sense stand still and black ran out of
time so he lost but even if he didn't if
he would play something like rook g3
black brings the Queen back and then
we'll start pushing the a pawn and when
so this is how you defend when you're a
pawn up you try to get the development
give some of those pieces back and then
you start taking some other stuff all
right let's take a look at Fisher's
second game in this variation so it's
again the wildest variation and the noid
or the poisoned pawn will be one Queen
a3
what's the key move here for white yes
what's the key move here for white no f5
is the older move was the key move here
yes yes Bonnie five takes takes 97
Bishop c4 so Tring of sometimes this
happens in professional chess you play a
game in one variation and others get
interested and say Oh Bishop e7 was a
little bit suspicious the way you played
in the previous game so Fisher Fisher
knows this and comes up with a different
move Bishop b4 so he plays Bishop b4 and
mix it up a little bit so his opponent
won't be in his comfort zone
rugby 3 and actually the point of Bishop
b4 is trying to win the night before
it's too late and in this way he's
gaining some
Tempe rugby 3 Queen a five castles V
Castle as well Knight takes c6 f takes
c6 Bishop takes c6 King h8 rook takes a
faith Bishop f8 Queen f4 now first we
have to identify what our opponent is
about to do to us what is his plan yes
No so the plan is not to take but
something even more crude yes yeah Queen
f7 and Queen g8 mate so if we play
something very soft like h6
the Queen would come much much closer
and we're about to get checkmated so
it's a tough task but we're Bobby
Fischer and we'll need to find a way to
get out of trouble here obviously what
does black doesn't have in this position
what is black lacking in this position
yes development so we will have to find
a developing move and also a way to stop
from getting mated naturally yes
night if I would leave the bishop on f8
undefended and that would be Queen f8
mate so you have to be careful with that
how can we bring more pieces into the
game any ideas how we could bring some
pieces in the game
in this position any ideas back there
how we could develop more pieces
anyone back there any guesses how we
could save ourselves
yes well yeah well that doesn't really
help now because they'll just take and
take our Bishop so one thing is it'd be
great if we would defend this c8 Bishop
somehow being a simple developing move
all right yeah
Queen one Queen d1 is not quite possible
here
Queen d8 Queen D then a bishop would
take so that's not what we're looking
for here yes knight c6 natural natural
move by Fischer but will he will still
have to prove what happens after Queen
f7
now this g8 square is super weak but he
finds a spectacular defensive move here
yes
97 then the bishop would take yes B&C 5
check yes correct King h1 and Knight f6
indeed this was actually Fisher's move
could have also been Fisher's home
preparation I wouldn't be surprised if
this was seen at his home because now
you're defending this G 8 squared the
bishop on that faith is defended and
also have he would take on f6 that would
run into some cute little ideas have a
black win in this position yes Bishop
takes c6 green takes c6 that's G and the
yam Queen takes g5 and this idea which
is very famous from old polo guy offski
variations this trick of putting your
knight and pre on f6 but the Queen
basically gets the piece back after a
takes and Queen takes g5 and he would be
up a simple piece so why decides to take
on c8 but here again Fischer is in his
element and finds another good move yep
what no.not Queen takes pawn because
that would hang the FA Bishop Fisher
found a nice little intermediate move in
this position yes can you people 98 98
could work
he found an even more aggressive and
active more active move yes yes Knight
takes e5 queenie 6 + IG 4 and suddenly
out of defending he's actually attacking
and wipe resigned
why did white resign what are black
threats in this position is actually not
just multiple it's kind of triple and
quadruple it's a lot of threats what
kind of threats does black have in this
position yes can you people yeah the
white king will be in trouble very soon
yes Queen f2 doesn't really threaten
checkmate
what are we threatening in this position
with Black Knight f2 check and also
let's say Bishop takes b7 then we have
Knight f2 King g1 Knight to h3 mpeg-1
mate but that's not the only threat we
have let's say he plays Bishop d7 and we
don't see neither f2 how else can we
learn in this position yes
so how can we in another way not have
two wins obviously but there's another
way to win this position yes Queen c7
but there's a much simpler Queen c7 wins
but there's another move that means
immediately
apart from Knight F - yes no yes
yeah Queen takes g5 and we're up many
many pieces so we saw how Fischer
defended these positions and basically
that's how he got rid of this variation
of it Bishop c4 nobody plays Bishop c4
anymore but this variation became very
popular again and we're going to switch
sides and see how danger it is to play
this position with black if they're not
careful enough ninety seven so we talked
about Bishop c4 here but that was
refuted by Fischer's Bishop b4 and
Bishop e7 as we saw previously so
players playing this line that white
realized that Bishop b4 is an annoying
idea how can we stop that now yes rugby
three is away but there's a more active
move that they found here and that is 94
white realize that okay maybe if I just
have quick development is not enough I
need to stop you from developing this
this Bishop for a while because you can
see that the bishop can move to e7
because then we take and the knight
would jump to d6 also Bishop b4 is not
possible now because now it's protected
by the rook and the Queen so black
played eight six
we saw this in Fishers game
he's trying to gain this this extra
Tempe because it might be useful later
on
Bishop h4 beam takes a two and actually
the tall game was in fact the rugby
three here but tall idea still lives in
the form of rook d1 which became very
popular recently
now black needs to bring his queen back
to d5 my place Queen III Bishop c5 and
if black manages to castle here at this
moment in this position then white would
be in big trouble because he's done a
lot of material but here white has a
spectacular move that will make it kind
of tough for black to move again it's
white to move and play a very good move
a very very entered entertaining move
yes
it's 96 then I'll take with my bishop on
d6
any ideas back there how can we attack
here with white yes
tonight b5 that b5 then black would just
take the night but is actually
surprising in this position that the
black king can suddenly be in in some
mating ideas yes
that's G&G three you may mean g3 no
because the Queen would take on e5 or
not not queen 85 then it would lose a
piece but most likely Bishop takes d4
works this is a problem it's really
unimaginable yes no but it's very night
at five is close but I'm not not the
exact the exact move yes
no because G would take the night yes
not b5 was already mentioned that if a
pawn would take it that's the problem
yes no Knight d6 the move that was
actually played was Knight takes c6
pretty beautiful
because if black would take the rook
which is the natural reaction takes and
this unusual mate would come 96
checkmate
spectacular
and if black would decide to take on e3
instead then we have 97 check and rook
takes d5 and white has very big
developmental advantage and after let's
say Rukh a 796 black is close to lost
and has maybe a pawn they're not even
upon the pawns are equal right now so
why just has an amazing position here
so because Queen takes ecigs doesn't
really work because Knight c5 or
spectacularly even Queen c5 is working
because night c5 runs into route d8 mate
so black decided to give a check so you
can get out of trouble now how should we
continue yes c3 yes c3 yeah correct
double attacking both the bishop and the
queen on d5 mean take c6
we capture back the bishop castle and
now white realized that he needs to put
a lot of pressure on blacks position so
it will collapse but where would be
preferred to put our bishop if we could
so choose yeah
[Music]
yes we'd love to put our bishop on c4
so therefore sheriff who's a legendary
player from the 80s and 90s and is
famous for his aggressive and beautiful
combinations he does his best so he can
actually put this beautiful Bishop to c4
what move did Sheriff play that allowed
him to post the bishop on c4 yes
wrote d6 Queen takes e5 and now comes
the move that visa
you've been daydreaming about and that
is Bishop c4 exactly knight c6 castles
and now again black faces the same
problems as in the previous fischer
games this rook is totally out of play
and it will take at least three four
moves to get it out
so black would like to defend the f7
pawn so he plays Queen h5 what will be
black's next move if he could move again
where would he position his pieces yes
yeah he'd like to position this knight
on e5 PNF 495 and it's not that this
position is easy but sheriffs make it
sheer of look makes it look easy if you
look at it and it's white to move and
he'll come up with a great sacrifice
indiscriminate in this position yes
Bishop takes f7 then the knight could
capture it back actually it's a
non-standard combination yes
Bishop f6 it's a typical idea but most
likely he could play some Bishop g4
Bishop e6 there's an even more forceful
way to punish black in this position yes
yeah yes you yes then G takes f6 so that
doesn't work Knight f6 doesn't work yes
Queen takes h6 then I'll take with the
Queen it would work if G takes age six
because Knight f6 check but doesn't work
yeah rook takes h6 indeed rook takes h6
so if pawn takes the knight f6 check so
the question is Queen takes h6
yes
Bishop g5 then the black queen would
move to h5 yes yes
not have six check very good forcing the
King in a corner because if black takes
that would lose the Queen King h8 and
now comes a silent move by white which
actually wins at all yes g4g for I would
just take the bishop yes Bishop g5 with
the idea of queen of Queen g6 yeah I
have Queen g6 then Queen h4 wins
so because if Queen 87 that's just
simple mate
[Music]